did you see some of the other images
that were out with these guys on bumper
cars and they took over an amusement
park and they were having fun i mean
they're trying to humanize themselves
and i agree people are you know
vulnerable to this messaging without a
doubt and the point i made earlier too
is
once mainstream media starts buying into
it which they probably already are you
know then there's another way you're
going to be subjected to it and you
mention kids i mean kids are getting
bombarded every single direction they go
college you know from professors
hollywood the in in elementary school
right now here's the next thing that
they're going to do the kids they're
going to segregate them on whether
they're wearing it or have been
vaccinated yet and the fda hasn't
approved the vaccine and you're talking
about 12 by the way culver city in la
just uh is the first school district in
la that is mandating that 12 and above
have to be vaccinated to go to school
all right they don't have this whole
home okay culver city school district i
still work in coverage yes right by sony
yeah sony right at valleys but so you
got to get vaccinated if you're 12 and
up yup to go to school this year they
just came out with it yesterday
yesterday or tuesday okay i know and
it'll fall like dominoes in the rest of
la i guarantee you here's here's what
i'm trying to like
what's the formula
people come to america for options and
choices how do you lead with force
you know for years we took flu shots and
we took vaccines it was a choice yeah
you took it
this is when you do force it's it's not
a marketing strategy that's effective
plus those vaccines were fda approved i
think you get a lot of people that are
just a little bit afraid of the fact
that it's not fda approved although it
could happen i heard by the end of
august but
yeah that's what kids are dealing with
right well look
to go back and and that's that's a whole
nother ball of wax man that the the
segregation that they're doing right now
and the stratifying of society between
the obedient and disobedient is
something that's that's really really
troublesome but i look i i have to admit
and i and maybe maybe the reason pat
that i feel the way that i feel about
this is because after 9 11 happened you
gotta you know i grew up in the shadow
of the towers uh i i i
became
there's no other way to say it like
islamophobic i really did i for a long
time for years after i was one of these
dudes that was like nah screw muslims
they're all the same they're this and
that like they they destroyed these
people
and uh dude i was wrong i was young you
know and i was i was flat out wrong so
when it comes to this you know i have to
wonder man like so much of
what's going on in afghanistan is the
fault of our government george bush
dick cheney donald rumsfeld the entire
you know establishment regime for
whatever reason whether it was oil
whether it was access whether it was
poppy whatever reason we were there to
we we weren't there for for the right
reasons and we we destroyed
an entire generation man and
you know that this is our cross to bear
in some ways and i'm not i look i'm not
pro taliban i got to say that as loud as
i can again but i also don't want to
fall into that same category of we're
the good guys they're the bad guys we're
we're on the side of righteousness yeah
they're on the side you know what we
have to have some enemies right because
right now i mean we do have legit
enemies but no one is hearing about that
and if you're a kid the messaging you're
hearing and if you're a vulnerable
person is the only enemy is someone that
doesn't believe in you and what you
believe politically or maybe socially
that that is the only enemy and that is
the only message these people here we
don't talk about
threats to this country and the legit
enemies that we have i am way more
worried about the fox and the hen house
than i am about the taliban six thousand
miles from me i have to be honest i am
way way way more concerned about ivy
league professors than i am about the
taliban right now i am way way way more
concerned about media executives inside
my own country than i am about the
taliban you're worried about shaping up
the mindset i am you're more worried
about that kami professor than you're
worried about the taliban no doubt about
it no doubt about it so you are the shah
you're thinking like the child you're
worried about a mindset spreading is
what you're worried about i i am worried
about things that i think that we can
control so here's a question for you i
got a question for you okay historically
do you know how the communist membership
has done have you ever studied how to
communicate
in the united states have you looked at
the names yeah what have you noticed
what have you found uh that when times
are bad membership goes up when times
are good membership goes down fraud out
and by the way how bad is a drop-off
when times are good yeah it's it's
almost to the point where they have to
make times better of course of course to
recruit but when the times are great
what happens to their membership they
fall away they fall away how bad is it
by five percent or like 80 yeah
everybody grows up essentially everybody
grows up 80 okay let me ask you a
question percentage-wise go from 1930
1940 when did karl marx start really
creating momentum what what you're well
19th century but yeah i would say the
bolshevik revolution okay end of world
war one so let's just go from there
let's go 20 yeah okay let's go 20s 30s
to today okay
go 20 30 still today
percentage-wise percentage-wise of
communism membership in u.s
is it the same today as it was 90 years
ago
it's an interesting question
percentage-wise yeah i'm not talking
number i'm asking persons yeah it's an
interesting question i it's probably
lower okay but i think it has way more
people in the mainstream sympathetic to
the idea sympathetic is different but
there are a lot of sympathetic people
you know moms are sympathetic to but you
know it's okay you know you should
forgive him it's okay it's okay to be
sympathetic but the membership has
declined is that a fair thing i wouldn't
think yeah i mean listen the ussr is or
or it's rebranded the actual communist
party has now got an element of
capitalism in it it's the government
that's communism that wants to control
the narrative but the business you can
go out and make money in china yeah it's
futile but yeah okay so so all i'm
saying to you is the idea of communism
has gradually lost momentum is that fair
percentage yes okay so now let me flip
the question on you here's a question
for you
go from
40 years ago 1981
to today
1981 to today
taliban hezbollah extremist any of those
like not not muslim the religion that's
the biggest i'm not talking to religion
i'm not talking about the people that
you deal with who are muslim who are
peaceful
loving caring they're just like how you
some how are you a muslim i'm a muslim i
follow some of the stuff that prophet
muhammad talked about
but has the taliban hezbollah isis have
they increased in the last 40 years yes
percentage-wise absolutely is it by
small percentage or by a big percentage
well it's it's by a big percentage and a
lot of that's our doing so what i'm what
i'm saying i i don't disagree
but their number one enemy in the world
is america
because everything america stands for
they don't stand for everything america
stands for they don't stand for they
want to do whatever they can for
everybody who represents the westernized
mindset to be
taken off of the face of the earth
anything to do to get rid of them the
point i'm trying to make to you is the
one you're worried about sometimes
is proving that it doesn't work they're
just a bunch of people that are going
around you know crying whining well it's
not fair let me tell you that with these
capitalists all they want to do is put
people to work and it's like slavery and
this this this the ultimate slavery is
communism let's face it that's the
ultimate slavery
but the one you have to worry about is
guys like this so for me when they're
okay with them creating this kind of
momentum just look at the percentage of
growth the last 40 years it validates
what we have to really be careful with
they flat out hate you
right they don't not like you they hate
you they want you dead they they wish
you were not here it's a very different
mindset so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]